bonjour merci à d'être avec nous bien de
le dire elle vient de le voir le conflit
est très tendue en irak
oui oui absolument parce que tout
simplement à la tête de ce gouvernement
vous avez un acteur un acteur de bonne
volonté il faut le dire avec doug un
projet autour du nationalisme irakien de
l'ira qui cite et de l'inclusion
politique social économique seulement la
tragédie du kasumi c'est qu'il vient
totalement désarmé il est désarmé parce
que tout simplement il est dépassé par
des crises structurelles de 2003 à 2020
les tahitiens l'impossible l'état
irakien à consacrer 400 milliards de là
pour mettre en place des infrastructures
au niveau de l'électricité
et comme vous l'avait bien dit dans
votre reportage à ce jour là les
températures arrive à 55 degrés et les
basses ravi n'ont que deux ou trois
heures d'électricité
alors il y est totalement désarmé par
rapport aux convives d'isner totalement
désarmé par rapport aux milices
totalement désarmé par rapport aux
torrents forces de l'organisation d'
états islamiques totalement désarmés
face au désengagement des états unis
d'amérique
il est homme est vraiment dans l'impasse
totale
justement le premier ministre monsieur
kazimi son poste et délicat beaucoup de
ses prédécesseurs ont échoué on le sait
est il l'homme de la situation parce que
vous le disiez vous ressentiez tous les
problèmes actuels en irak n'ont
absolument pas il n'est pas l'homme de
la situation à il y a
il y avait été le premier ministre tout
simplement parce que l'effort les
acteurs forts du champ politique
irakiens n'ont pas réussi à mettre en
place un accord pour former un
gouvernement fort capable de gérer la
situation
de ce fait ils ont cherché lucknow
faibles parmi eux et ce pour faire le
bien évidemment a été mon staff à 15 me
il n'est pas l'homme de la situation
pour toi parce qu'il n'a pas un parti
politique sociale solide parce que tout
simplement il n'a pas des députés parce
que ce simplement il n'a pas une base
militante
il est tout seul avec quelques
intellectuels à la tête d'un
gouvernement où il n'a aucun pouvoir sur
les ministres lient sur les ministères
alors irak l'irak est en tête en dans le
classement des pays les plus corrompus
la corruption c'est d'ailleurs une des
luttes à des manifestants depuis des
mois quel est le levier actionné pour
mettre fin cette corruption qui
manifestement gangrène le pays
peu probable il est peu probable parce
que l'état irakien de 2003 à 2020 a été
refondée reconstruit sur deux principes
a peut-être vous serez étonné mais
malheureusement c'est la réalité le
premier principe c'est ce que j'appelle
dans mon livre l'impossible est taillé
raillant la milice isation de la société
irakienne
le deuxième pilier ou le deuxième
principe de sur lequel l état irakien a
été refondée c'est la systématisation de
la corruption
aujourd'hui attaqué à la corruption
s'est attaqué au système 15 nuits du
même qui est un enfant légitime de ce
système
alors les manifestants bien évidemment
dénoncent la corruption mais dénonce
également à l' influence régionale de
l'iran mais également des états unis sur
le pays est ce que justement ces
revendications elles ont pas ample pris
le dessus sur les revendications
économiques et sociales
il y a à la fois à les revendications
sociales économiques mais aussi les
revendre à des revendications politiques
pourquoi parce que tout simplement le
mouvement de contestation n'est pas
homogène mais hétérogène il y a
plusieurs catégories engagées dans ce
mouvement de contestation
chaque catégorie à ses priorités par
exemple la catégorie jeunes entre 14 et
22 ou 23 ans aux îles sont plutôt à dans
les revendications socio économique mais
la catégorie intellectuel très engagé
dans le mouvement de contestation qui
est plutôt du côté des revendications
politiques
alors on dit ardèche coronavirus
économie à bout de souffle une classe
politique un peu un peu faible le
premier ministre irakien en tout cas
toute la classe politique irakienne a
beaucoup de chantiers beaucoup de
priorités dans ce pays
oui beaucoup d'autres priorités mais
malheureusement pas pas beaucoup
d'acteurs nationaux
autrement dit vous avez des partis
politiques des organisations des
fractions des blocs politiques et qui
sont constitués et par définition à
l'échelle communautaire
vous n'avez à ce jour là aucun parti
politique avec un projet national les
cheats vote pour les chiites les
sunnites vote pour des sunnites et les
kurdes pour les kurdes les chrétiens
pour les chrétiens alors autrement dit
la grande tragédie irakienne de ce jour
là vous avez à l'irak mais vous n'avez
pas désiré lyon vous n'avez vous avez un
état mais vous n'avez pas un projet
national
l'irak est structurellement fracturée
alors vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
canicule on en a parlé dans le reportage
à 55° parfois plus une très forte
canicule qui sévit en ce moment en irak
et ne pénurie d'électricité mais aussi
d'eau pourquoi les enfants structure
irakiennes sont elles aussi faible un
petit rappel dans les années 70 l'irak
était parmi les pays les plus avancés
les plus développés au moyen orient
son système d'éducation santé économique
était tellement solide
on parlait même du maire du modèle
irakien du rêve
eva tient à généraliser à l'échelle
moyen-orientale mais à partir de de la
guerre iran irak de 1980 à 1988 et
ensuite l'invasion du koweit et ensuite
l'embargo sur l'irak dont 90 à 2003 et
ensuite l'occupation de l'irak par les
états unis d'amérique la guerre contre
l'organisation du hadj à peu près 35 ans
de guerre de guerre a détruit totalement
toutes les infrastructures du pays
adel bat cornes merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous je rappelle que vous
êtes directeur du département recherche
de l'institut de recherches et d'études
méditerranée moyenne orient merci
beaucoup